it's monday and we're talking mass
effect legendary edition possibly coming
to xbox game pass some fighting game
news and more
the mass effect legendary edition might
be heading to xbox game pass as early as
this week according to an apparently
accidental listing on the xbox store
according to the polish website xgp and
reported by vgc the remastered
collection of the original mass effect
trilogy was briefly listed with the game
pass logo on its box art this has been
an indicator in the past that an
announcement was imminent but also in
some cases just an error ea publisher of
mass effect offers its own subscription
service ea play as a part of xbox game
pass ultimate its vault of games is
routinely updated with new additions
with most new releases finding their way
onto the service within a year after
release with mass effect legendary
edition having launched in may 2021 this
timing might have been accelerated
despite the collection selling beyond
ea's expectations developer bioware is
currently working on the next iteration
of dragon age but continues to tease the
next entry in the mass effect series
earlier this month an image emerged that
showed the return of the geth with
previous crew member liara also expected
to make a return and potentially star in
the sequel but no release date or window
has been shared
riot games revealed more information on
project l a 2d fighting game set in
runeterra in a video the leads on the
upcoming project went into detail behind
the corey gameplay for the title as an
assist-based fighter players will build
a team of two different champions that
they can switch between during a match
and the game is said to reward strategic
team-building on-the-fly decision-making
and strong fighting fundamentals
gameplay teasers showed off a handful of
champions from league of legends
including ahri and darius but the
project l's dev leads doug into a
singular character's kit echo this
champion in project l possesses time
manipulation abilities and the center of
his kit is a forward moving slash called
chrono strike the ability generates an
after image that players can rewind to
and rewinding can be used to stack
combos and keep opponents guessing
echo's next location ekko's ranged
attack is called time winder and it's a
bomb-like attack that can slow echo's
opponents for a few seconds taking into
account echo's entire kit it's fast
paced and likely requires someone with
dexter's fingers and quick reaction
times riot games developers emphasized
that their goal is to create easy to
learn and difficult to master combat
kids they also touched on netcode
assuring players that the team was
working on creating a seamless combat
experience riot direct an internal
system that minimizes lag for league of
legends will also be used for project l
and a seamless lagless online experience
for fighting games sounds like a dream
as for when project l is likely to come
out it could still be a while the core
gameplay has been established but more
champions kits need to be fleshed out
stages need to be designed and ranking
systems have yet to be built riot stated
that the next update will likely come
early in the second half of 2022 and it
will aim for at least two updates next
year
and keeping on trend with some fighting
game news street fighter's most popular
characters are crossing over to
ubisoft's free-to-play fighting game
brawlhalla ryu chun li and akuma from
the capcom series have arrived in
brawlhalla as a part of the game's
latest epic crossovers event ryu will
have his iconic tatsu shuryukin and
hadouken chun li will definitely be
showing up with her spinning bird kicks
and kiko shows and akuma with his own
tatsu air fireballs shoryuken and more
in addition to the famous fighters
brawlhalla has introduced a new mode
called street brawl which puts a street
fighter spin on the game featuring
health bars that street fighter fans
will definitely recognize the mode also
has new ko techs inspired by capcom's
game and a new satsui no hado emote
brawlhalla also adds a new 1v1 map
inspired by the suzaku castle from
street fighter and there are also four
new avatars based on zangief the shadolu
symbol and a hadouken we also have a
really cool video about the history of
the hidukin on our channel by our very
own kurt indovina if you want to know
more about that iconic move
and the gta trilogy is the game that
truly keeps on giving the more players
dive into it at video tech underscore
posted a video on twitter showing off
some unfinished vr capabilities found
with a debug command in unreal you can't
view it in first person but it
apparently plays fairly well what's the
wildest glitch you've found in the gta
trilogy so far let me know in the
comments below and be sure to like and
subscribe so you don't miss your next
gamespot news update
[Music]
you